it's on the safety Marcus hooker a
former Buck
ey mord on third down open Harrison
Marvin Harrison Jr no chance touchdown
Ohio
State MC time taking a chance Endzone
open that is caught touchdown Marvin
Harrison Jr for the second time today
these Buck guys on that
sideline
it's a long throw it's Harrison nobody
around Marvin Harrison Jr Walts is in
watch you got two guys on him Anthony
Johnson the corner you got the safety
over the top and Weber and you got
nobody that can run with number one 18
every time they've touched the ball mord
on first down looking goes deep mcord
wide open receiver caught Harrison and
Marvin Harrison
Jr mcor pump looks sideline caught
Harrison Jr again he'll dive for second
and 33 he'll Force this one down the
field over the shoulder and is
[Applause]
caught third down and 10 mcord sets up
over the middle of again this time it'll
stand Marvelous Marvin
Harrison second and eight out of the gun
mord again backpedaling firing left
sideline Fleming fighting for it
Harrison Jr down the field on the out
and up for a huge explosive play that's
a nice ball there now G Scott the tight
end flank wide to the bottom of the
screen back pedaling McCord lofting to
the end zone caught that's a
touchdown as Martell Tate checks into
the game wide to the left Harrison's to
the right Marvin Harrison catches he
makes the move 30 25 Marvin Harrison
down the sideline
mord over the middle Harrison Jr again
Mazerati
marah touchdown tight end CED over
either third and six mcord LS it
Harrison makes the
grab mcord Under Pressure hit as he
throws End
Zone touchdown morvin Harrison manto man
coverage are bringing pressure off the
edge and they're going to go toward
Harris and he turns makes the catch he
hangs on keeps one foot in as he beats
longer
be take it to Henderson pitch it
Harrison open space there he goes morvin
Harrison Jr touchdown oh with a true
freshman chance
Rucker and they are looking for the End
Zone Harrison oneon-one
he's got it a oneman wrecking crew Morin
formation they saw there was no safety
help and and you're not going to win
one-on-ones against Marvin Harrison
beautifully thrown Ball by Kyle McCord
over the outside shoulder impossible to
defend and sides finds way to get him
the football for looking for him deep
down the middle Harrison's got it
tripped up across the
25 mcord to throw it lobs it in the air
back shoulder caught at the 45 Marvin
Harrison
Jr
mcord steps up in the pocket throws it
deep mcord caught at the 40 yd line
Maserati Mar and a flag on the play was
hanging all over Marvin Harrison and
onehanded he's able to bring that one in
and mcord hung strong in the pocket took
a big hit from Mason Graham there right
after he released it but he mcord will
let it fly over the middle caught
Harrison touchdown masera Mars Marvin
Harrison Jr with the 14 yd score
oh